bonjour à tous il ya énormément de
rumeurs sur ce que pourrait être
l'iphone les iphones et 2018 et
justement on va faire un petit peu un
tour d'horizon voir un peu les
différentes rumeurs voire qui profile
voir ce qu'on va voir arriver dans cette
année 2018 et ça justement aux affaires
[Musique]
apple c'est vraiment un sujet dont on
parle énormément pourquoi parce que
apple a toujours une capacité à
réinventer le marché et à proposer de
nouveaux produits qui sont toujours plus
intéressant sur l'univers des
smartphones en ce moment c'est un peu
moins vrai il ya une très grosse
concurrence
il ya vraiment le marché chinois qui
poussent derrière il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'entreprises qui
innovent et proposent des produits
différents des produits intéressants et
des produits qui sont plus destinés au
gamer des produits plus vidéo des
produits de plus photo apple dans tout
ça garde toujours une stratégie haut de
gamme pour ses produits apple à bouger
un petit peu bousculé les codes en tout
cas bousculer ses propres codes la
dernière en lançant l'iphone 10 l'iphone
qui a rencontré un certain succès mais
qui de notre côté a été aussi un petit
peu décevant justement 2018 apple
devrait proposer de nouveaux produits
c'est ce qu'on va faire on m'arrête dans
cette vidéo dans un premier temps les
caractéristiques techniques de ce que
pourrait être l'iphone ou les iphone de
db 18 et à la fin je vais vous dire ce
que moi j'attends est ce que j'espère
qu'on retrouvera cette année voire
peut-être l'année prochaine dans ses
futurs ses futures versions l'iphone
d'ailleurs en préambule est ce que vous
pouvez me dire vous ce que vous attendez
d'apple est ce que vous avez déjà un
iphone 10 est-ce que vous avez des
iphone plus anciens même si vous n'êtes
pas chez apple vous pouvez répondre
qu'est ce que vous attendez de ses
futurs iphone
dites moi tout ce que vous en pensez et
est ce que vous pensez qu apple a
toujours une grande capacité
d'innovation et est-ce qu'apple peut
vraiment nous surprendre mark et moi
tout ça on en discute ensemble parce que
voilà ce que sont vraiment des sujets
qui sont hyper intéressant pour
commencer apple arrêterez la production
de son iphone 10 et ça dès cet été
je n'ai pas déjà dans une précédente
vidéo que je vous invite à aller voir on
devrait retrouver cette année trois
nouveaux iphone peut-être quatre
nouveaux iphone un iphone 5,8 pouces
avec un écran oled un iphone 6,5 pouces
avec un écran oled un iphone 6,1 pouces
avec un écran lcd est peut-être un
iphone est ce version numéro 2 l'iphone
est ce version 2 pour l'instant on ne
sait pas trop parce que même si
effectivement il ya vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'infos et beaucoup de
rumeurs dans ce sens il se pourrait
qu'apple n'ait pas les moyens
lancer quatre nouveaux iphone cette
année or est effectivement dans
l'expectative
on verra bien toujours est il que c'est
cet iphone et ce est lancé il le sera au
dab dab eu lieu ainsi enjoint de l'année
prochaine donc on sera très très très
prochainement informées alors qu'est ce
qui pourrait arriver en septembre
prochain
comme je vous le disais trois nouveaux
iphone un nouvel iphone 10 un iphone 10
plus et un iphone 10 versions mais grand
guinéens ce qui se bat pour les
guillemets mais version low cost parce
que chez apple le low cost est pas
vraiment ce qu'on peut appeler du low
cost mais pour apple c'est du low cost
on devait débuter devraient avoir
l'arrivée de la puce à 12 qui
permettrait effectivement d'avoir
toujours plus de puissance de calcul
aller encore plus loin dans la réalité
augmentée est peut-être toucher du doigt
la réalité virtuelle des smartphones qui
devraient avoir une plus grande capacité
de calcul est aussi un peu plus de
mémoire vive il faut savoir quand même
que l'iphone disque est censé être un
des modèles référence n'a que 3 j g
c'est-à-dire un moment vous avez des
produits qu'on lui giga de ram comme le
web + 5 t vous avez des produits qui
s'apprête à sortir avec 10 gigas de ram
vous avez un galaxy note 8 avec 6 giga
de ram et vous avez le produit phare
d'apple
la plus grosse marque de smartphone le
leader du marché qui vous sort son plus
gros modèles avec 3 giga lan
alors bon il vous le sorte vous ne savez
pas pourquoi vous ne savez pas d'où
effectivement on imagine que tout est
très très bien optimisé pour que ça lui
permettre de fonctionner suffisamment
avec sa puce à 11 bionique y avoir de
bonnes performances mais sur le papier
on est quand même hyper surpris donc les
iphone de 2018 pour gagner un point en
giga octet drame est arrivé jusqu'à 4
gigaoctets de ram
côté batterie on voulait avoir des
batteries en elle on devrait avoir des
batteries encore plus puissante et avoir
25% de durée de vie en plus pour
l'iphone avec l'écran 5,8 pouces on
pourrait avoir une batterie de 2800
milliards erreur pour l'iphone avec un
écran de 6,5 pouces on pouvait avoir une
batterie de trois mille trois cent
millions paire eur quant à l'iphone avec
un écran lcd de 6,1 pouces on pourrait
avoir une batterie de 2950 milliampères
heures donc des batteries un peu plus
puissant que son trouve actuellement
chez apple autre info et les modems kiss
pas se connecter en 3g et en 4g dont
pour passer vos coups de fil si vous
voulez nous passons très classique les
modèles qui sont fournis historiquement
par qualcomm pourrait être entièrement
fourni par intel
alors in théâtre intervient déjà sur la
fabrication de certains modèles d'iphone
cette es7 plus mais il devrait gagner
davantage de terrain il doit y avoir
effectivement un switch entre qualcomm
intel alors vous de votre côté en termes
d'utilisation ça changera pas grand
chose mais d'un point de vue fournisseur
d'un point de vue stratégie il ya un
sens derrière pour apple et on imagine
très clairement que ça se fait en termes
de coût d'achat donc en termes de marges
pour apple
bien évidemment ces des modèles qui ont
toujours fait ça dit il y aura toujours
les animaux de j que vous ayez
d'ailleurs un smartphone avec un écran
oled ou un écran lcd peu importe cette
technologie vous permet effectivement de
déverrouiller sans tête shahidi c'est à
dire un grand écran sur la face avant
le design serait le même de celui de
l'iphone 10 de 2017
avec toujours la petite encoche ans
roland koch effectivement a fait
beaucoup parler d'elle on a l'impression
que c'est encore ça fait beaucoup plus
parler d'elle que le produit en lui-même
parce qu'elle a vraiment séparé un petit
peu je dirais le public en deux d'un
côté les personnes utilisent ça a son
charme sa un sens et une caméra trop deg
toute façon il doit être là c'est permet
effectivement à l'écran d'aller toujours
plus haut donc pourquoi pas et il ya de
l'autre côté ceux qui n'aiment pas du
tout et qui disent non c'est encore est
moche c'est une espèce de verrue au
mieux ce téléphone est rien pour
s'attacher très pas côté design on le
regardait à l'arrière un dos en verre
pour avoir une recharge à induction il
est très clair qu'apple est parti dans
ce sens ils vont y rester
on devrait néanmoins garder le port
lightning pour pouvoir avoir
l'adaptateur pour la prise jack pour
avoir une recharge rapide pour avoir
aussi une recharge classique et pour
pouvoir brancher si besoin déjà que ce
soir alors ses iphone de 2018 comment
pour utile ça plaît on va très bien
qu'on a eu l'iphone l'iphone 3g l'iphone
4 25 est sacro sainte cécile 16,7 +88
lice ont chacun fait une version pseudo
raccourcis et là on est arrivé à
l'iphone 10 l'iphone des dix ans donc on
voit très bien qu'il ya pas eu d'iphone
est-ce qu'on a un sens à sortir un
iphone 11 parce qu'on sait que dit
c'était pour les 10 ans là sur les onze
ans passera un petit peu redondant
garder la dénomination iphone disent
pourquoi pas mais on est plus sur les
dix ans et l'appeler le
6 s je trouve ça un peu moyen 10s 10,16
plus strict en a qui vont prononcer le
10 x parce qu'ils voient une croix même
si c'est pas un x1 10 mai avec un x et
un s à côté ça fait xs ça fait small
c'est très bizarre et je pense pas
forcément une bonne idée d'un point de
vue marketing
donc comment vont s'appeler s'est
produit a tendance à penser que peuvent
prendre deux pistes soient effectivement
dire iphone + l'année et l'iphone de
2018 les ponots 2019 etc
mais bon c'est pareil c'est pas terrible
terrible et puisse aller de la phase
aller perry beaucoup plus vite
et d'un autre côté ce qui à mon avis y
aurait plus de sens c'est avoir une
dénomination comme on retrouve sur leur
nac coes c'est-à-dire jaguar panthères
snow leopard high sierra et c'est donc
pourquoi pas à voiron 2018 un iphone
high sierra ça pourrait être plutôt pas
mal voir plutôt sexy
d'ailleurs dit moi ce que vous en pensez
maintenant je vais vous dire ce que moi
j'attends de ses iphone qui vous faire
part de mes sept points que j'aimerais
bien voir arriver ou voire améliorées
sur ses iphone de 2018 le tout premier
c'est la réalité virtuelle
alors je ne suis pas sûr que ça arrive
cette année chez apple mais c'est vrai
qu'on rentre les casques de réalité
virtuelle sont des choses qui se
démocratise énormément on peut
effectivement faire choix avec son
iphone d'utiliser un casque de samsung
ou autre casque si vous le souhaitez
c'est à dire qu'il vous suffit de
prendre votre smartphone vous le
positionnait comme ça un peu à l'arraché
pour fermer ça tiens vous fait un casque
de verrières donc là j'ai de la réalité
virtuelle directement sur un iphone bon
pourquoi pas mais on pouvoir aller
beaucoup plus loin parce que là vous
avez pas de collectif c'est-à-dire que
vous posiez que me regarder des
applications qui ont été fabriquées pour
la réalité virtuelle arrive aux
smartphones c'est pas du tout optimisé
il nous faudrait donc un casque de
réalité virtuelle qui exploiterait le
port à lightning que vous avez ici
ou alors imaginez un smartphone un
iphone avec des petits connecteurs de
type connectique qui viendrait au plus
bon là à mon avis on n'y est pas encore
peut-être pas pour 2018 mais c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui m'intéressait
parce que la réalité virtuelle comme la
réalité augmentée sont vraiment deux
points qui développe énormément et
clients une vraie utilité au delà du
gaming
ça peut être pour la productivité donc
pour le travail ça paye pour beaucoup de
choses
donc j'espère qu'apple va développer son
propre casque de réalité virtuelle
d'ailleurs dit mon commentaire si ça
pourrait vous
c'est le deuxième point c'est la
recharge rapide parce qu'effectivement
apple vont son iphone 10 avec un câble
de recharge parle pas au lightning
mais c'est pas du tout de la recharge
rapide dont il serait quand même
intéressant que sur des produits de plus
1000 euros qu'ils puissent intégrer une
recharge rapide
d'ailleurs on peut aussi leur reprocher
qu'ils ont énormément communiqué sur le
fait que l'iphone qui se recharge par
induction sauf que le chargeur par
induction il n'est pas du tout dans la
boîte donc si vous le voulez il faut la
sauver ou plus dont qui aura vraiment
associer à ce qu'apple nous vendre un
produit qui se recharge par induction
avec une recharge par induction
effectivement ça permet à apple de
vendre des accessoires qui vont vous
facturer un certain prix si vous voulez
une recharge rapide
vous allez passez à la caisse si vous
voulez acheter un chargeur à induction
vous allez effectivement aussi passer à
la caisse
on comprend effectivement que les
chiffres d'apple augmente toujours parce
que de toute façon on vous vend toujours
plus de choses on vous créez des besoins
et après on vous les factures je suis
pas sûr qu'elle peut en attaque s'est
produite directement dans sa boîte
mais bon ça sera quand même bien ça me
paraît normal de le faire côté photo
j'aimerais bien qu'il y ait une
ouverture variable c'est des choses qui
vont beaucoup développée en 2018
conduire trouver chez samsung très
prochainement
et ça me paraîtrait logique qu'apple
allait là dessus pourquoi pas sur le
modèle plus le plus grand modèle en 6,5
pouces pour pouvait très bien imaginer
avant l'ouverture de 2.5 2.2 lorsque
vous auriez beaucoup de lumière ambiante
mais dès lors vous auriez beaucoup ma
lumière une ouverture en 1.8 1.6
ça pourrait être intéressant on pourrait
aussi imaginer à l'avant un double
module photo pas pour avoir
effectivement un tel objectif parce que
vous n'avez pas besoin lorsque vous
allez me prendre cette fille 1 voulait
absolument voir ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de votre nez si vous avez
des copains dans mais sinon mise à part
ça ça a un sens pour le mode portrait
pour l'améliorer pour éviter qu'une fois
qu'une correction logicielle mais
qu'avec les deux caméras vous aviez
vraiment quelque chose de 100% optimisé
je prie pour le retour du port jack
je pense que je peux rien y faire cuire
un oeuf je pense que je rêve je pense
que ça n'arrivera jamais mais je prie
pour le retour du port jack si on n'a
pas envie d'acheter des irp aussi on n'a
pas envie d'avoir un casque bluetooth
etc on a comme moi un vieux casque qu'on
aime dont on n'a pas envie de se séparer
regardez moi mon bon vieux casque lamont
sonimaux nder sont 15 06 que j'ai depuis
des années que j'adore avec cette petite
connectique là c'est tout petit
connectique
j'aimerais bien encore en garde
et pouvoir l'utiliser sur un iphone
glisse voir les versions qui vont
arriver après j'ai pas nécessairement
envie d'avoir un adaptateur j'ai branché
dans mon port lightning adaptateur jack
de l'autre côté je trouve que c'est
moche ça fait rajouter on puisse y ait
un problème d'équilibré au niveau du
point ça ça pèse quand même lourd donc
vous déciderez adaptateur de tout et
lightning
ça c'est l'ours pas pratique s'il vous
plaît apple je sais que vous allez
perdre au niveau de l'épaisseur mais par
pitié
remettez mois une prise jack je ne sais
que suis pas le seul à la réclamer
j'espère aussi une meilleure autonomie
comme je vous le disais l'iphone disent
effectivement vrai dur et une grosse
dizaine d'heures en fonction de
l'utilisation qu'on en a reçues sur
variable si vous êtes tout le temps
penché sur votre smartphone en train
d'écrire m'envoyer des messages deux
jours des choses comme ça vous allez
consommer énormément
si vous mettez la luminosité à fond vous
allez consommer énormément ça c'est très
logique pourquoi avoir une batterie de
2007 116 millions terreur sur l'iphone
10 sur l'iphone référence ça me paraît
un petit peu light par rapport à la
concurrence c'est vrai que l'autonomie
ne se joue pas que sur la capacité de la
batterie elle se joue sur l'optimisation
de l'ensemble de la machine mais
néanmoins plus vous en avez sous le
capot et plus vous pourrez en faire
et justement en parlant de ça j'espère
plus de puissance pourquoi 3 giga de ram
alors que vous avez des concurrents à 8
10 gigas de ram comme je vous le disais
pas c'est uniquement à cazilhac drame
ça fait un peu petit bras même dans
l'idée ou le produit 100% dit miser on
va se dire effectivement s'optimiser
vous avez la puce à 12 qui travaillent
parfaitement bien avec 4 gigas de ram
vous avez pas besoin de plus mais sans
papiers du point de vue consommateur
vous voyez des smartphones à 6 8 10
gigas de ram vous aviez votre nouveau
modèle que vous payez plus de 1000 euros
et il a 4 gigas de ram
vous avez l'impression de faire un bond
dans le passé face il ya un moment ça
paraît pas logique tout ça il ya
probablement des raisons techniques
derrière mais d'un point de vue purement
consommateurs on dit qu'il ya un truc
qui cloche et dernier point le prix 1159
euros pour un smartphone avec 64 giga de
stockage et 1329 pour 256 gia est
effectivement le smartphone est bien la
marque est une marque premium qui se
paye cher mais ce que c'est pas un peu
trop cher du point de vue consommateur
en tout cas pour moi c'est un frein
après son très bien que les chiffres
d'apple sont toujours à la hausse que
les marges sont belles que le 4e sommet
de 2007 a été un record de chief pour
apple
ok ok mais
il ya un moment l'envolée des prix doit
s'arrêter
elle doit juste s'arrêter parce que ça
devient des collants c'est clair qu
effectivement on est plus sur un simple
téléphone avec quelques options on est
sur un assistant de vie miniature
personnalisés mais bon des smartphones a
plus mille euros moment ccc plus que la
démesure
ça tient quand même dingue alors si on
garde cette logique on voit très bien
qu'à une augmentation des prix donc dans
deux ans
combien vous coûte et nos smartphones
est-ce qu'on se retrouve avec des
smartphones à 1500 2000 auront ça peut
paraître un peu démago ce que je vais
dire mais me semble pas que la cour des
salaires et la courbe de prix des
smartphones soit exactement la neige
alors vous me direz on n'est pas obligé
d'acheter chez apple vous avez des
smartphones très bien chez le milieu de
gamme vous avez effectivement one plus
vous avez au nord vous avez plein de
marques qui sont très bien vous allez au
wec il faut aussi d'excellents produits
qui sont pas toutes aussi cher mais si
on veut en produits d'apple
on a quand même deux courbes qui sont
bien distinctes salle de l'augmentation
des salaires et celle de l'augmentation
des prix chez apple ça c'est un peu le
un peu le coup de gueule
donc voila un petit peu pour faire un
point sur ses futurs iphone de 2018
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez est
ce que ça pourrait vous intéresser est
ce que les dernières vous avez changé
pour le 8,8 plus ou l'iphone bis et si
c'est pas le cas est-ce qu'en 2018 vous
seriez prêt à changer
mark et moi tout ça c'est très
intéressant de prendre ces tendances et
le pouvoir ce concours de ce qu'ils
nomment où on se situe par rapport à
tout ça je vous remercie comme
d'habitude avoir regardé cette vidéo je
vide comme d'habitude a blessé des
jolies pousse à vous abonner parce qu'on
appareils toujours plus toujours mieux
de high tech activer la cloche
restez connectés je vous envoie très
fort et à bientôt
[Musique]